KATIE PAVLIK, DANA PERINO,
JUAN WILLIAMS, AND
JESSE WATTERS.
"THE FIVE"."
NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
EVERY TIME A CRISIS OF PEERS,
THAT FOLLOWS.
TAKE DEMOCRAT JACKIE SPEIER WHO
TRIED TRUMP FOR NOT CANCELING
RALLIES OVER THE VIRUS.
>> THE FACT THAT HE IS NOT
WILLING TO CANCEL HIS VARIOUS
RALLIES SUGGEST THAT HE IS
WILLING TO PLACE AND EVEN HIS
MOST SUPPORTERS AT RISK.
I THINK THAT HE IS SHOWING
UNFORTUNATELY WHY HE IS SO
ILL-PREPARED TO GUIDE OUR
COUNTRY DURING THIS TIME OF
CRISIS.
>> Greg: LIKE SHE CARES FOR
HIS SUPPORTERS.
SO WHY JUST DEMAND THAT FROM
TRUMP BUT NOT BERNIE OR JOE?
IS A JUST A COINCIDENCE SUCH AN
ORDER COINCIDES WITH THE
POLITICAL AGENDA?
WHAT IS THE NEXT DEMAND?
THEY SHOULD VOTE IN NOVEMBER
JUST TO BE SAFE FROM THOSE TALKS
IS CONTAGIOUS VOTING BOOTHS.
NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO THE
WAIST, THAT’S WHAT THEY WERE
THINKING WHEN THEY THINK THE OIL
MARKET AND PUT ANOTHER NAIL IN
THE COLLUSION COFFIN.
THEN THERE IS CHUCK TODD’S
WISHFUL THINKING, THERE’S A
VIRUS COULD BE TRUMP’S IRAN
HOSTAGE CRISIS.
>> JUST BEFORE THE BREAK, WHAT
THE IRAN HOSTAGE CRISIS WAS IN
THE FINAL YEAR OF CARTER’S
PRESIDENCY NOT HIS FAULT BUT
IT’S A TEST IN REAL TIME AND
THIS IS WHAT THIS SEEMS TO BE.
>> WHAT THIS DOES HOLD THE
POTENTIAL TO BE A JIMMY CARTER
SITUATION WHICH IS I CAN’T WAKE
UP WITH HIS ANXIETY EVERY DAY,
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME LEADERSHIP.
TO MIX CHUCK SAYS THIS IS WHAT
IT SEEMS TO BE FOR TRUMP.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE A FACT TO
YOU?
YOU CAN BLAME THIS IDIOCY ON
POLARIZATION, BUT THE SWINE FLU
KILLED THOUSANDS UNDER OBAMA AND
I DON’T RECALL THE MEDIA
ATTACKING HIM LIKE THIS BECAUSE
HE WAS THEIR GUY.
THEN THERE WAS
HURRICANE KATRINA, A DISASTER
MADE WORSE BY CORRUPT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT THEY BLAME
GEORGE BUSH BECAUSE HE IS A
REPUBLICAN AND NOT THEIR GUY.
SO IF THEY HATE THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT THAN CRISIS AS THEIR
TOOL.
WHAT’S NEW IS A PRESIDENT WHO
RESPONDS IN KIND BECAUSE THAT’S
TRUMP.
NOW, HIS FEISTINESS WON’T SLOW
OUR ABILITY TO HANDLE THIS
THREAT.
IT’S WHAT GOT HIM TO CLOSE THE
BORDERS.
WHAT HE DOES OR DOESN’T DO WON’T
MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE TO THE
PRESS.
NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO WASTE,
THEY THINK.
MAYBE IT WILL HELP THEM IN
NOVEMBER.
JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HOW THINGS ARE GOING?
>> Jesse: I WOULD SAY THEY ARE
LIKE A FOOD CRITIC THAT CAN’T
COOK.
ALL THEY DO IS CRITICIZE AND I
WAS THINKING OF BARACK OBAMA
PRESIDENT DURING THE
CORONAVIRUS, THE MEDIA WOULD SAY
HE’S DOING A GREAT JOB EVEN IF
HE WAS IN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN A VERY
AGGRESSIVE WITH THE TRAVEL BAN
INCOME OF QUARANTINE,
ACCELERATING OF THE VACCINE AND
HE’S BEEN OUT ON TELEVISION
EVERY SINGLE DAY TAKING
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS AND
TELLING PEOPLE TO GO TO WORK AND
REMAIN CALM.
WHAT IF HE DONE THE OPPOSITE?
WHAT IF YOU STOP SHAKING HANDS,
WHAT IF HE DID CANCEL RALLIES,
WHAT IF HE HELD HIMSELF UP AND
REFUSED TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND
WHAT WITH THE MEDIA SAY THAT IN?
THEY WOULD SAY THE PRESIDENT
DIDN’T HAVE A GRIP ON THIS, HE
WAS TOTALLY AWOL AND HE WAS
FEARMONGERING.
SO NO MATTER WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DOES, HE’S GOING TO GET HEAT FOR
IT.
THE POINT IS THIS, IF YOU
CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT, DO
SOMETHING WITH SPECIFICS.
DON’T JUST SAY HE’S BEEN AN
ABJECT FAILURE AND IS UNPREPARED
UNPREPARED.
IF YOU SAY THERE IS MIXED
MESSAGING, HAVE AN EXAMPLE, BUT
NOT JUST SAY THIS IS A SAMPLE
HERE FROM THREE PEOPLE.
TRUMP IS A SOCIOPATH OR PARSLEY
TAKING THE MARKETS, HE IS A
FAILURE, A B.S. ARTIST AND HE
HAS AN UNSCIENTIFIC RESPONSE.
THAT’S JUST NOT TRUE.
GAVIN NEWSOM, GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA WAS ASKED HOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DOING AND HE
SAID EVERY TIME WE’VE ASKED FOR
SOMETHING, THE PRESIDENT HAS
RESPONDED IMMEDIATELY AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS GIVEN US
EVERYTHING WE NEED SO IT’S NOT
TRUE THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
MISHANDLING OF THIS.
THE MEDIA’S MISHANDLING THIS
TRYING TO PRESS THE PANIC BUTTON
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS AND
THAT’S FINE.
THE PRESIDENT JUST NEEDS TO SAY
DON’T TOUCH YOUR FACE, DON’T GO
ON A CRUISE, EVERYBODY REMAIN
CALM.
WE’RE GOING TO HANDLE THIS,
AMERICA ALWAYS WINS, WE ALWAYS
BEAT THESE THINGS, LET’S DO
THINGS MADE IN AMERICA, TIGHTEN
THE BORDERS AND WE ARE GOING TO
BEAT IT AND IF HE STICKS TO THAT
MESSAGE, THAT’S A STRONG
MESSAGE.
>> Greg: LET ME PLAY
RAHM EMANUEL TALKING ABOUT THE
RALLIES AND I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON THE RALLIES IN GENERAL.
>> YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE A POINT
WHERE YOU CAN HAVE BIG EVENTS
TOGETHER.
>> HE IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THESE RALLIES AND HE IS
GOING TO PSYCHOLOGICALLY --
THEIR OFFICES ISOLATING ENOUGH
AND HIS INABILITY TO GET THE
ADULATION FROM THAT CROWD IS
GOING TO PSYCHOLOGICALLY TORMENT
HIM AND IS GOING TO GET MORE
INTENSE IN HIS TWEETS ARE GOING
TO GET MORE VICIOUS.
>> Greg: I THINK IT’S A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION ABOUT
RALLIES, WHETHER TRUMP OR
BERNIE.
I THINK IN THE AGE OF PEOPLE
THAT COME TO THESE THINGS, I
WOULD BE CONCERNED BUT HE
POLLUTES THAT MESSAGE BY TAKING
SOME KIND OF PERVERSE PLEASURE
OUT OF IT.
I CAN’T TRUST THAT GUY BECAUSE
HE’S FINDING A POLITICAL
PLEASURE, RIGHT?
>> Juan: LIKE GOING OUT HAVING
A PRESS CONFERENCE ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS WEARING A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT HAT, FOR CALLING
THE GOVERNOR OF WASHINGTON A
SNAKE.
I THINK THAT IF JACKIE SPEIER’S
IS THE EXAMPLE YOU HAVE OF -- I
DON’T SEE DEMOCRATS BEING SO
POLITICAL ABOUT THIS.
IN FACT, WHAT I SEE IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED.
THEY WANT RELIABLE STRAY
INFORMATION AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID IN THE PAST IF YOU WANT
TO TEST, YOU CAN GET IT BUT IT
TURNS OUT THEY WEREN’T AVAILABLE
FOR THE PRESIDENT SAYS THIS IS
JUST LIKE THE FLU, NO BIG DEAL,
WE HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL ON THE
NUMBERS KEEP GOING UP AND PEOPLE
BECOME MORE TIGHT AND THAT YOU
HAVE REPUBLICANS MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS SAYING THEY ARE SELF
QUARANTINING.
>> Greg: WHICH MAY BE AS KIND
OF LOVE.
>> Juan: I’M JUST TELLING YOU
THE TRUTH, THAT’S A FACT.
AT THE MEDIA DIDN’T TELL
TED CRUZ.
I DON’T CARE IF THEY GET A KICK
OUT OF IT.
I’VE ALWAYS SAID TO YOU, WHAT WE
SHOULD BE CARING ABOUT HERE IS
PEOPLE WHO WERE ANXIOUS AND
WORRIED ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT IS NOT SEEN AS RELIABLE AND
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PULLS MOST
AMERICANS DON’T THINK HE’S DOING
A VERY GOOD JOB WITH THIS.
PUBLIC POLICY POLL JUST SAID
THEY DISAPPROVE OF HIS CONDUCT
OF THE HANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A POLL HERE
THAT SAYS HE’S IN POSITIVE
DOUBLE DIGITS IN EVERY SINGLE
BATTLEGROUND STATE.
THREE THIS POLL CAME OUT
YESTERDAY SO THE POINT IS, ALL
OVER THE MAP, THE BIGGEST TRUE
TEST IN TERMS OF ANXIETY IS A
STOCK MARKET WHICH ABSOLUTELY
IMPLODED TODAY AND WHAT YOU SEE
IS PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS AGAIN
ABOUT LACK OF KNOWING WHERE WE
ARE GOING, WHAT IS A SITUATION.
>> Katie: THIS IS A TEST FOR
THE PRESIDENT, ABSOLUTELY TRUE
AND IT’S A BIG ONE.
ALSO DOING TWO THINGS AT ONCE,
NOT OVERREACTING, NOT UNDER
REACTING, THINGS ARE GOING TO
CHANGE EVERY DAY.
THE NUMBER OF CASES ARE GOING TO
CHANGE, THE CDC AND THE
PRESIDENT HAVE TALKED ABOUT SO
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT FROM DAY-TO-DAY.
SO YOU CAN’T ACCUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF NOT BEING RELIABLE
JUST BECAUSE INFORMATION IS
CHANGING IN THE ADMINISTRATION
IS HOLDING A PRESS CONFERENCE
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND ALL OF THESE
OFFICIALS TO GIVE A DAILY UPDATE
DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
DIRECTLY TO REPORTERS TO TRY AND
LET THEM KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
AND HOW THEY CAN BEST HANDLE THE
SITUATION.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
POLITICS OF THIS, THE DOW
ESPECIALLY IS THE EXACT ECONOMIC
COLLAPSE THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR.
BILL MAHER SAYING HE HOPES THE
ECONOMY WOULD COLLAPSE, HE
DOESN’T CARE IF IT HURTS ANYBODY
BECAUSE THAT’S HOW HE KNOWS THE
PRESIDENT WILL GET OUT OF
OFFICE.
THE ECONOMY WAS THE BIG BARRIER
FOR THE DEMOCRATS WHEN IT CAME
TO WINNING THE WHITE HOUSE THIS
TIME AROUND AND NOW THEY ARE
LOVING THE IDEA THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY BE TAKEN OFF
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL BECAUSE HE
CAN HOLD RALLIES, THAT HE MAY
HAVE TO SELF QUARANTINING AND
NOT BE ABLE TO TALK DIRECTLY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND PUSH
BACK AGAINST MOMENTUM THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOW IN THE
PRIMARY PROCESS.
COUPLE THAT WITH THE ECONOMY,
THEY LIKE THAT MOMENTUM GETTING
PULLED AWAY FROM THE PRESIDENT.
SO THINGS WILL CHANGE, THIS IS
CHINA’S FAULT, CHINA DID THIS TO
THE WORLD BY THE COMMUNIST PARTY
IN CHINA COVERING THE SET.
THEY CENSORED IT WHICH MADE IT
SPREAD AND THEY LIED ABOUT IT
AND THAT’S WHY WE ARE HERE.
WE ARE NOT HERE BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT BECAUSE
AMERICANS ARE HERE BECAUSE OF
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE CRITICIZING
MORE ON THAT THAN THE PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: THE IMPACT ON THE
STOCK MARKET WAS IN THE
CORONAVIRUS.
MIGHT’VE BEEN PART OF IT BUT WE
HAVEN’T OIL PRICE WAR GOING ON
THAT’S HAD AN IMPACT.
>> Dana: I AM NOT A BIG MARKET
EXPERT BUT I COULDN’T SAY IT
DOESN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
LAST WEEK IT DID, IT HAD
GYRATIONS.
AND OVER THE WEEKEND,
SAUDI ARABIA AND RUSSIA DECIDED
THIS WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD TIME
TO HAVE A PRODUCTION MORE AND
START HAVING THIS ARGUMENT OVER
THE WEEKEND AND THAT MEANS IF
YOU WORK IN THE ENERGY FIELD AND
THAT OIL IS DOWN TO $31 A
BARREL, THAT’S A PROBLEM FOR THE
ECONOMY AND FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN IT AND I ALSO THINK IF I
COULD HAVE ONE SECOND.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO GET
CRITICIZED NO MATTER WHAT, SO
IT’S FINE.
WHAT SHOULD THEY TRY TO DO
MOVING FORWARD?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE MADE A
MISTAKE ON EARLY ON WAS WHEN THE
DOCTOR FROM THE CDC SAID AN
OUTBREAK IN AMERICA IS
INEVITABLE AND SHE GOT PUSHED TO
THE SIDE.
SHE WAS RIGHT.
THERE WAS AN OUTBREAK BUT IT WAS
A MANAGEABLE OUTBREAK.
ALL OF THIS IS MANAGEABLE.
I THINK WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
THE TEAM AND MAYBE YOU’LL HEAR
FROM VICE PRESIDENT PENCE HERE
IN A MINUTE THAT GOING FORWARD,
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE OUR HOSPITALS AND OUR
MEDICAL TEAMS ARE OVERWHELMED,
THAT IS JUST GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO HOW ARE WE PREPARING FOR THAT
THAT, AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEING ABLE TO RELEASE TO THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON
THE FRONT LINE, SET EVERYTHING
WE’VE ASKED FOR WE HAVE RECEIVED
RECEIVED.
THIS IS LIABLE TO HAPPEN,
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE FINE,
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD THING TO
DO.
TO BACK MY QUESTION IS, WE TALK
ABOUT OVERWHELMED MEDICAL
FACILITIES BUT WHAT DO THEY DO
WITH ALL OF THOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FLU PATIENTS SINCE
WE KNOW 50 TO 80,000 AT TIMES
DIE?
WE NEVER HEAR ABOUT THAT.
>> Dana: WE HAVE TREATMENTS
FOR THEM.
THERE ARE VACCINES OR SOMETHING